so it's basically a method by which you
can look in the human genome and let it
it's a discovery tool right you look in
the human genome and you see what what
is emerge what's been become really
common and prevalent and therefore must
be important for our survival and the
things that you find our interesting
emil a lot of them we like to say are
very its skin deep so a lot of them is
to do with pigment when you look in
Europe and Asia is the lighter skin
those are things that have become very
common it looks like hair in Asia so
like hair and sweat glands in the Asian
population have been under evolutionary
pressure so a lot of things that just
allow you to interact with the
environment this seemed to be under
potential pressure and then lactose
tolerance is another big one so the
ability to drink milk again it's an
effect as our nutrition as our sources
of food change our metabolism changes in
how we how we use those resources so
those are the kinds of things that we
find but the one of them to me the most
interesting with my background in my
sort of clinical background and MD is
that the other thing that's very
strongly under selection is things that
are known to protect from malaria and
things that seem to be involved with
infectious disease so it makes sense
that you know as we're moving to
different environments and climates
we're changing our sort of skin and
they're sweating patterns to deal with
to thermoregulate and deal with the sort
of sunlight pressure as we change our
you know domesticate plants and animals
we're changing our metabolism and what
we're using as nutrient resources and as
we deal with lots of infections so
parasites bacteria viruses that are
interacting with us all the time we need
to survive and so when I was looking
through the genome you know I kind of
honed in on originally I thought I was
developing the test looking at jeans
that were protected from malaria seeing
these kinds of patterns and I need you
look through the whole genome the the
things that protect from malaria seem to
be evolving and then more recently this
is all very preliminary but it looks
like a bunch of genes that are involved
with lasa hemorrhagic fever which is a
hemorrhaging fever that people get also
seemed to be an evolutionary pressure so
it's kind of pointing me to pathogens
are very important
evolutionary pressure to humans and
what's very interesting is that what's
so interesting about pathogens is you
know they're themselves changing so
rapidly so we see how we evolve and
adapt to them that they're also
continuing to evolve and adapt to us so
it's this moving target and their
genomes are much like ours and we can
study them in the same way and see how
they survive as we look in the human
genome when we look to see what's
evolving what's protective from you know
and and the things so far that we've
identified important and infectious
disease we like malaria's when we
understand a lot so we can see where
those genes that protect from malaria
seem to be under strong evolutionary
pressure and the kinds of things that we
see is in the gene hemoglobin the sickle
cell mutation g6pd deficiency you see a
lot of things that are involved in
immune response or t-cell response and
so you see both red blood cell because
mullerian invades the red blood cells so
both receptors on the red blood cell and
things are important in the constitution
of the red blood cell under strong
evolutionary pressure and also things
important in the immune system so and
one of the other genes is cd36 which is
a receptor on endothelial cells so we
see how both the immune system and the
red blood cell are very important in
malaria pathogenesis and that genes that
are within those sort of within the
immune system and red blood cells are
often under natural selection for
protection from malaria what's nice is
that we have a lot of candidates that we
already know to be functionally
important right so we can look around
those and that's originally when I was
developing the test i was i was looking
around genes had already knew that were
protected from malaria that we'd have an
expectation that they would be under
natural selection right so they cause
resistance to malaria malaria been
around for a long time and that you
might expect to see them rise to the
population so that's basically the test
that I was working on is about that it's
about distinguishing just a random event
and a random mutation that's common in
the population versus something that was
sort of become became prevalent to
rapidly to happen by chance alone so you
know what we do is you go through
and we look across the genome when we
look for things that are very prevalent
and things that are very young and we we
have a way a threshold of saying this is
too young to become this prevalent by
chance and so it hasn't been around long
enough that it just sort of randomly got
to this prevalence well we do this part
of we do we know part of the story as to
why some people get malaria in living
some people get malaria and die so there
are like said malaria's very complex
organism and the way that it invades and
effects and it causes lots of different
symptom ologies like cerebral malaria
severe malaria nemia there's a lot of
interactions that are going on with the
host with a human and so we don't
understand every aspect of the disease
but we do know some of the mutations
that allow people to survive and we
understand partly how that works and
again those have to do with things that
are expressed in red blood cells or
they're important for red blood cells
and things important in the immune
system
you